uh you've argued that true ai if it's
realized might pose a danger that
exceeds
every previous threat from technology
even nuclear weapons
and that if its development is not
managed carefully humanity risks
engineering get its own extinction has
your position changed with that are you
still in the same place with that yeah i
mean in terms of the magnitude of threat
if we're talking about probability that
obviously
goes up and down over time so
when
uh
scientists first detonated
an atomic bomb the trinity test
that was some concern that
maybe the high temperatures that will be
generated could ignite the atmosphere
then that would kill our life
concerned enough that
a number of studies were
commissioned by uh
robert oppenheimer was the director of
the lasalle muslim and
those calculations that were performed
show that this
shouldn't happen
like in terms of the nuclear physics
like the new atmosphere is not ignitable
and of course they detonated the bomb
and the atmosphere didn't ignite which
is a good thing for us
um
but at the time you might say that was a
small
existential risk that their calculations
maybe could have been mistaken and then
that would have been the end and in fact
just a few years later when
scientists were
developing the fusion bomb the the
hydrogen bomb
they again made some calculations as to
the yield of this experimental device
that they were going to detonate
and
they set it off
um
castle bravo detonation and and there
turned out there was a mistake in their
calculation with the result that the
yield was uh two and a half times bigger
than they had anticipated and so what
this meant was that
a huge blast arose
irradiating a japanese fishing boat
where one person died causing an
international
accident you could imagine the japanese
be kind of sensitive to nuclear after
what they had gone through several
islands had to be evacuated and it was
like a big calamity a lot of the
instruments they had set up to to to
record the detonation were destroyed by
the blast so
it's a good thing that the calculation
error was in this
second experiment rather than in the
calculation about whether the trinity
test would ignite the atmosphere but
then i think there were maybe larger
existential risks during the height of
the cold war where the arm the world
seemed to be on the brink of nuclear
armageddon on several occasions
um
although it's not clear that that would
have caused human extinction
um
but now i think uh
if we're looking ahead over the coming
decades the biggest existential risks
and i think that would be
unprecedentedly big will arise from some
technological breakthroughs we
can be expected to make a super
intelligence being one and then like
synthetic quality being another and
there might be some further arias as
well that could introduce these new
factors into the world where we have no
track record of living with this for
many years or decades or millennia
and we're kind of rolling the dice a new
with these brand new powers so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]